albert einstein quien dijo no es que sea
tan inteligente es solo que persisten
los problemas más tiempo
thomas edison probó 10.000 iteraciones
fallidas en su búsqueda de la
construcción del foco eléctrico antes de
que realmente funcionara
compara esto ahora contigo sentado en tu
sillón y acomodando las piezas de un
rompecabezas diez mil veces antes de
completarlo
de esta forma en realidad no hay
diferencia en lo absoluto entre este
cuestionamiento y cualquier otro que nos
encontremos en la vida
el cerebro aspira certeza prácticamente
de la misma manera que necesita la
comida y el sueño
conseguimos satisfacción al contar con
la información que nos hace sentir más
seguros
por eso como humanos nos encanta seguir
reglas y caminos pruebas prefabricados
estudia esto consigue un trabajo seguro
cásate haz una maestría etcétera
etcétera al contrario tenemos una
respuesta fuertísima de amenaza hacia la
incertidumbre sobre lo que va a pasar en
el futuro que nos incomoda y nos empuja
a gravitar hacia la certeza
pensar en nuestros desafíos y objetivos
como propuestas aleatorias e intangibles
es lo que nos obliga a tirar la toalla
no hay nada de que agarrarnos
evitar los riesgos y dejar de un lado
los desafíos que no parecen funcionar en
el primer intento
tim orden en su blog wave' uruguay pone
esto en perspectiva la historia de la
humanidad si fuera un libro de 800
páginas la historia registrada
representa 24 páginas o 6 mil años
primeras ciudades y agricultura antes de
eso
otras 24 páginas el resto de la
existencia humana 700 52 páginas de
cazadores y recolectores
184 mil años nuestro cerebro evolucionó
y se adaptó para operar durante estas
700 52 páginas no las 24 en las que
hemos estado viviendo últimamente esto
significa que nuestra cabeza de mono
está acostumbrada a lidiar con problemas
de vida o muerte no con nuestros
problemas modernos lo que nos hace
lidiar con las cosas de una manera de
vida o muerte
básicamente exagerando todo
sobre lo que realmente es la victoria o
el fracaso
necesitaríamos entrar en la mente de
cada persona para determinar
pero podríamos estar seguros de que está
extremadamente sesgado por las
construcciones sociales y por nuestros
sentimientos algo que siempre me he
cuestionado es cómo sufrimos por seguir
un camino prefabricado
el camino correcto
algo con lo que personalmente lucho
todos los días estudia mucho consigue
los trabajos correctos aunque no te
gusten haz una maestría cásate jubilate
muere desvía te del camino y estás loco
desvía te y fallaste tienes estas reglas
en serio tomémonos un minuto y
reflexionemos quien en la tierra tiene
autoridad real sobre que es que ni
siquiera nuestros cientos de deidades a
lo largo del tiempo se ponen de acuerdo
acaso tu vecino jefe padre amigo lo que
sea lo sabe pregunta interesante
nadie pondré un rompecabezas nuevo sobre
la mesa y esperaría acomodar todas las
piezas de una vez ni 10 piezas tenemos
claro como el agua que se tiene que
hacer pieza por pieza
empiezas por las pistas más fáciles los
márgenes tal vez algo en el medio luego
otras piezas van a encajar
cuantas más piezas acomode es más fácil
es acomodar más hasta que terminas un
rompecabezas de caja no involucra
sentimientos y si hacemos los
sentimientos a un lado lo mismo aplica
para los problemas son tanto más
intangibles que tenemos en la vida sólo
tenemos que mirar los de la misma manera
iteración paciencia empezar lento
construir completar diferentes sectores
y saber que hay un camino más adelante
para conectarlos
el principio siempre va a ser lo más
confuso y lo más lento pero entre más
avanzadas más claras se convierte la
imagen de lo que se está consiguiendo y
exponencialmente hasta terminar
porque perseveramos de todo corazón en
un reto así con paciencia y dedicación
pero no en los desafíos que enfrentamos
en nuestra vida diaria
es sólo una cuestión de perspectiva
que si nos entrenamos a enfrentar todos
los retos como si tuvieran una solución
absolutamente certera como ese
rompecabezas en una caja esta realidad
nos relajaría para seguir intentándolo
hasta que finalmente encontremos una
solución y algunos dirán que tal si
simplemente lo que estoy intentando no
tiene una solución en este preciso
momento
cuando sigues intentando con algo que
parece inútil tal vez signifique que la
imagen completa del rompecabezas no es
la que crees que es sino algo diferente
que necesita ser integrado y visto de
diferentes maneras para ser entendido
si una pieza de un rompecabezas no
encaja físicamente en el espacio en el
que necesitas llenar en este momento no
significa que no pueda encajar en el
futuro pensemos en esto directamente ese
trabajo esa persona esa idea de negocio
el hecho de que no sea cómoda en este
preciso momento no tiene ningún sentido
ni significado
hay piezas que primero es necesario
acomodar para que su espacio venga
después
si existe una solución simplemente hay
que darle paso con una pieza anterior
que podemos no estar viendo en este
momento es una profecía que se cumple
sola
el concepto de profecías que se cumplen
solas no sólo es importante en la
investigación psicológica sino que
también es un fenómeno bien conocido en
el campo de la sociología
donde fue descubierto y definido por
primera vez por el sociólogo robert
merdzo merton acuñó el término profecía
que se cumple sola definiéndola como una
definición falsa de una situación que
evoca un nuevo comportamiento que hace
realidad la concepción originalmente
falsa
en otras palabras más fáciles merton
noto que a veces una creencia trae
consecuencias que hacen que la realidad
coincida con lo que creíamos
generalmente quienes están en el centro
de una profecía que se cumple sola no
entienden que sus creencias causaron las
consecuencias que esperaban o que temían
atención en cómo es un arma de doble
filo
muy frecuentemente
involuntario a diferencia de la
automotivación o la autoconfianza
estos estudios se insinuaron la idea de
que nuestras expectativas de nosotros
mismos no sólo influyen en los
resultados o la falta de
sino que nuestras expectativas de los
demás también tienen un impacto en
nuestros pensamientos y sentimientos y
comportamiento que tenemos hacia ellos
cuando queremos algo sobre nosotros
mismos es más probable que actuemos de
manera que corresponda con nuestras
creencias
reforzando así nuestras creencias y
fomentando el mismo comportamiento
una vez más la imagen final en esas
piezas en la caja del rompecabezas
confianza y motivación para una
determinada solución sin importar el
tiempo o el esfuerzo más allá de esto
está la percepción de que un fracaso o
como mi me gusta llamarlo un intento es
un fracaso final y aquí es donde podemos
hablar sobre el camino y no el resultado
cómo podemos determinar si fracasamos en
completar algo podríamos argumentar que
lo único que tenemos que hacer para
eliminar la definición del fracaso de
una situación es alejar nuestro punto de
perspectiva
si esta pieza que en este momento tome
de la mesa no tiene acomodo bien no
significa que falle completando el
rompecabezas por completo momentos días
o cualquier tiempo que tenga que pasar
después en el que esa pieza por fin
encuentra su espacio nos confirma que el
fracaso temporal fue solo una
interacción necesaria para el resultado
final y la necesidad de tener
perspectiva
el fracaso es tan natural con atrevernos
como la mediocridad es con el no hacerlo
cada texto sagrado o mito fábula que se
nos ocurra gira en torno a un tema
central quienes se enfrentan a desafíos
son recompensados y quienes no lo hacen
están condenados o como joseph campbell
lo llama en su libro el héroe de las mil
caras el camino del héroe cuando promete
o se atrevió a robarle a los dioses
sufrió mucho pero su osadía trajo el
precioso regalo del fuego al mundo
cuando hércules se atrevió a embarcarse
en un viaje de introspección se enfrentó
a grandes peligros pero regresó como un
héroe
despertar mañana a las seis de la mañana
un rompecabezas fácil ser presidente un
rompecabezas gigante con un millón de
piezas del mismo color
pero podríamos argumentar en contra del
hecho de que si encaja ciertas piezas en
un orden determinado con suficiente
persistencia a lo largo del tiempo
tendría una solución a caso no otras
personas en la historia se han
convertido en presidentes
en situaciones psicológicas es menos
fácil de lo que parece pensar así
no debemos de creer en el destino sino
más bien creer que tenemos el control de
cada posible iteración de nuestra
realidad
en nuestro universo en la expansión
reflexionemos que existe una iteración
en la que nuestro objetivo es real
ya sea que escojamos pensar en esto de
manera tan relativa o en una manera más
práctica estoy convencido de que aplique
como dijo confusión el hombre que mueve
una montaña empieza cargando pequeñas
piedras piedras pequeñas piezas pequeñas
acciones pequeñas lo que la montaña es o
su tamaño depende de ti
muchas gracias